el zonte es una pequeña comunidad
costera famosa por la fuerza de sus olas
pero en 2019 la oleada de olibet coin
cambiaría para siempre el destino de
esta concurrida playa
somos los primeros en el país que empezó
bitcoin somos quienes sembramos la
semilla ahora el mundo entero tiene sus
ojos sobre el salvador
esa semilla nació por un donante anónimo
quien decidió patrocinar con bitcoins
los proyectos sociales que jorge lidera
desde casa esperanza con una sola
condición impulsar a una economía basada
en la cripta moneda
kvitko ya ha sido el programa más
emblemático que el país ha tenido como
lo dijo el presidente tomamos la copia
del sostén de bitcoin beach es cesante
lo logró lo puede lograr el país
pronto la ola se extendió y 200 atm
dedicados a la cripta divisa han sido
instalados en todo el país el pequeño
negocio de orlando está más que listo
para este nuevo momento
todos estamos esperando bajar la ual y
para dar el impulso sin embargo algunas
personas ya vinieron y me ha dicho va a
aceptar vi con el dios ya estoy listo
el gobierno ha ofrecido el equivalente a
30 dólares en bitcoin a quienes
descarguen el archivo ballet la
billetera electrónica oficial en su
celular pero el incentivo no ha sido
suficiente para romper la apatía dentro
de la población
no sé preparada para usar ese bitcoin yo
digo que hay mucha gente no solo yo que
en veces andamos telefonía gente que ni
ni teléfono ni cómo usar un teléfono
porque tenían que haber dado este
primero este mucha orientación verdad
pero no importa que que haya entrado ya
porque realmente no vamos a entrar de
lleno todo va entre los economistas la
alta volatilidad del bitcoin es la
principal objeción cuando nosotros
estamos pasando de mercados seguros
digamos de transacciones seguras que se
efectúan a mercados especulativos
estamos poniendo a la economía realmente
en una situación bastante compleja diga
el salvador es el primer país del mundo
en dar curso legal a la cripta moneda el
tiempo de gracia el plan futurista de
replicar el experimento del son t eso no
el camino para dinamizar la economía
real